but I do want the experience of like
gamedays partying I don't really care
about school as you guys don't know well
she might not be attending school
anymore but Olivia might still be
getting to experience those parties she
was so excited about fans are buzzing
after youtuber Heath hussar posted this
video to Instagram partying at fellow
youtube star david dobrik house in LA
because they think that's Olivia in the
background
oopsie David's rep is saying it wasn't
Olivia Jade in the clip but it's going
to take more than that to convince the
internet otherwise the 19 year old has
it posted on her own social media
platforms since news broke that her mom
and dad Lori Loughlin and Massimo
Gianelli were allegedly involved in a
College Admission scandal but Olivia is
friends with David so the internet might
just be right on this one I wish her the
best obviously of course et caught up
with David at the Kids Choice Awards in
March and he opened up about how his
friend was doing amid the drama I
haven't gotten to talk to her a lot but
she's she's a sweet smart girl so I'm
sure she's holding up good it's it's the
worst to get involved in anything bad
Olivia's parents have been accused of
paying $500,000 in bribes to get her and
her older sister Isabella into the
University of Southern California by
deeming them as recruits to the crew
team even though they never participated
in the sport Lori and Massimo both
pleaded not guilty to the charges
against them earlier this week they were
then charged in a second superseding
indictment on conspiracy to commit fraud
and money laundering and a legal expert
Rachel Stockman told et things could get
ugly I think that there are several
risks if she does not take a plea deal
here and decides to take this to trial
for one all the evidence is going to
come out in the public against her and
that could be potentially very
embarrassing - you also have the
potential that the feds could add more
charges if they uncover more evidence
that is not favorable to Lori I think
the likelihood that
spends prison time is very very high
because of the seriousness of the crime
and the amount of money that we're
dealing with here now a source close to
Olivia tells ET that she had her sister
knew their parents were using a man to
help them get into school but they quote
didn't realize the extreme lengths they
went to I want them to be happy so I
want to be supportive of everything they
want to do but I do want them to have
somewhat of a normal you know finish out
high school college experience the
source added that the sisters thought
that the money quote donated was going
to scholarships for crew team students
quote Olivia's still mad at her parents
and terrified at the idea she may have
to testify against them
[Music]